Canary Islands screams,
asks for help,
shouts to all the canaries,
to those who were born on this earth
and those who feel like such because they live in it.
They respect it,
they value it
and know the environment
in which it finds itself and which they enjoy.
And like 1 little boy screaming and coming down to his aid,
go to the street 20 de Abril
in every 1 of the points that have been established
in the different Canary Islands.
I will be with my soul and my heart because I cannot,
I am convalescent from 1 operation
and it is not possible for me to move
to that rhythm.
But from my heart I tell them
that this earth needs to be heard now.
Definitely
there are people who do not have to
to know the Canary Islands and you will wonder,
Well, what's going on?
I'm just going to put you
1 brushstroke of background
because I'm going to leave you with 1 video
who will explain it to you
all Moscow.
Channel is of 1 archipelago of 8 islands
and that it is very distant
of the country to which it belongs,
Spain.
We are glued to Africa
and we are 1 outermost region of the European Union.
Evidently
is 1 fragmented territory
which occupies about 7,500km2 does not reach,
We live 2,240,000 people living on this earth,
currently
300 people per square kilometer.
This is a very high statistic,
skips the 2nd National
and the rest of the Spanish autonomous communities.
Natural areas
protected in the Canary Islands
There are 146 and they occupy 1.40% of this territory.
Canary Islands currently have very tense areas
for the canaries.
We live off tourism,
is our engine.
This is not 1 demonstration against tourism,
but of the economic model
and tourism management.
We cannot deny that this is our engine.
In fact,
we are visited by 14 million tourists a year,
surpassing Australia
and on the other hand,
surpassing Brazil.
But the detail is that we are the worst.
quality of life we have in Spain
and we are at the forefront of unemployed people
in Spain in the number of unemployed.
So, here
what's going on?
The wealth that tourism is giving.
Reinvestment and diversification must be
on earth
that provides the resources to achieve this economy.
so strong that tourism gives and that the archipelago gives.
For those who did not do well
what they claim and vindicate,
I include myself within
this manifestation.
I will leave you with 1 video
by Gustavo who explains it divinely.
1 canary that goes around the world
and who has made 1 beautiful video
and that it is worth seeing.
I leave you with him.
1 of the largest
biodiversity jewels is about to collapse.
And yes,
I am talking about the incredible Canary Islands.
From the beginning of its development,
The Canary Islands have invested everything in mass tourism.
totally un
and this has caused us such serious problems.
as inflation of 90%.
of the fish of our coasts.
30 And 6% of the population
at risk of poverty and social exclusion,
the discharge into our ocean of 100
million liters of fecal water
per day,
the loss of 85% of its forests,
macro-construction financing
without up-to-date evaluations
as in the case of phonsalia and of the soul,
or the disproportionate increase
of the price of housing in 1
78% in recent years,
homes acquired,
admittedly,
in more than 1,
28% by foreigners not resident in the Canary Islands.
All these problems
come due to 1 lousy tourism management
who totally forgets about his people and his land.
And far from looking touristophobic,
what we demand is not to eliminate tourism,
is that the ones above
realize that this makes no sense at all
and can thus adopt
more conscious business models
and real measures to bring to your people and your land.
Measures such as
tourism rates
to reinvest
in protection of their natural areas,
integration and preference
of the Canary Islands in the labor sector
and housing,
urgent implementation of protected natural areas
that guarantees the integrity and development of our
and its wonderful
biodiversity,
regulation
and disposal of fecal water waste
that the only thing they do is to cheer us up
and destabilize our ocean,
the hotel and ovacation,
thus paralyzing the new
constructions and returning the earth to nature
or industries such as agriculture,
o 1 transition
towards 1 Green Mobility model
with greater and better infrastructure
by public transport.
That is why my people from the Canary Islands
this April 20,
whatever island you are on,
Take to the streets to fight for your rights and your future.
and if you are not from the Canary Islands
to get your support no matter what,
because the Canary Islands are a real paradise
to which it evidently
everyone wants to GO,
but we cannot forget the most important things
and we must try to please
to revert from scratch
all the damage that has been done so far
and focus on ethical progress,
sustainable and conscious
for the future of these 8 wonderful Canary Islands